foreign
how was the hypothesis formed at all
that
ketamine
instead of a million other interventions
or pharmacological tools
might be useful for
preparing the
structural damage of stress or
alleviating Depression was it something
that was observed in the field for
instance one of the rumors that I've
heard is that veterans who are
administered this anesthetic seemed to
experience less PTSD that was somehow
recorded in the field and that led to
hypothesis generation and and use of
ketamine that it seems pretty tenuous I
don't know if that's true but how did it
go from
anesthetic to
of all the things we could choose we're
gonna mess around with ketamine
first off I love hearing stories about
how I I and Dennis came up with ketamine
for depression but it's one of my like
people uh you know it's like oh that's a
great idea no
to be clear this isn't specific to you
it's just I I I'm so fascinated by the
the Genesis stories of these things I
think they're important so I'd love to
hear the the real story as opposed to
the Santa Claus version so the real
story
is not related to depression at all it's
related to to schizophrenia so it so
happens
in the great Cosmic
Universe of coincidence
that
a friend of my dad's in Detroit
friend of our and his family was a
friend of our family and we went on
vacation together
I remember
inner tubing down a river in northern
Michigan I grew up in Michigan inner
tubing down a river
with his daughter we were maybe 10 or 9
or 10 at the time his daughter is now
is named Joan Luby
um she's now an endowed Professor an
expert in child psychiatry at Washington
University in St Louis
anyway this fellow's name was
um
Elliott Luby
and in 1959
he published a paper
that was the first time fin cycladine or
cernal was given to a human being
this happened at the Lafayette clinic in
Detroit an entity a building which no
longer exists unfortunately in extremely
extremely
generative place in its era
and he said that if you gave cernal
which which was the company name for
pencilidine PCP angel dust if you gave
it to people It produced something like
schizophrenia in them
the thing was that's 1959.
and the mechanism the fact that it
blocked the nmda glutamate receptor
wasn't identified until the mid-1980s or
in 83 84.
so
it was this
fascinating observation which couldn't
go anywhere scientifically but they did
research and this is going to bring us
to other topics that we'll probably talk
about
in which they compared the effects of
pencilidine to the effects of LSD in
people yeah good old psychomimetic yeah
it's just just unbelievably courageous
and creative trailblazing
psychopharmacology at a time when they
just had no idea what was happening in
the brain the neurobiology
and in the early 60s
another trailblazing scientist also
associated with that group was a guy
named ed Domino
who was a pharmacologist it's a great
name too yeah my cousin Tom I apologize
for mentioning his name who is a medical
student at the University of Michigan
brought me to sit in one of his classes
when I was
applying to medical schools and it just
happened to be Ed Domino and my friends
my cousin and his friends when Ed Domino
came up to talk saying a bit of the Van
Morrison
song Domino
may be familiar with anyway
Unforgettable to me because Ed became a
very dear friend and colleague over the
years but Ed
was the first to give ketamine to
animals and humans and because it was a
shorter acting safer version of a small
structural modification
in the van cycladine chemical structure
that made it possible to
be shorter acting more manageable easier
to control and for what reason was he
administering the ketamine in in those
particular studies for anesthesia for
anesthesia got it yeah there was a
fellow Corson who was working with him
on some of those studies
so there's a line that I love you know
one of these I love
portentous lines in scientific
literature
like I think it's the last line in the
Watson and Crick discovery of DNA where
they say
it has not escaped our notice that the
elucidation of the structure of DNA may
have relevance for
the transmission of genetic traits or
something like that something
unbelievably understated
and there's a line in one of the first
papers on ketamine that Ed Domino wrote
which was when you give ketamine to
humans we notice that sensory
information can get to sensory cortex
unimpeded but is altered or or blocked
in its transmission to Association
cortex we call this
dissociation
and this process dissociative anesthesia
something like that and wow what a
profound cast off sentence right and
buried in the discussion of a paper in
an anesthesia Journal but really what
happened was that this group of pioneers
had an incredible tool but no conceptual
framework to use it to generate
in a real deep scientific insight and
and that's because they were
30 years ahead of the field yeah
something like that and
you know it wasn't even known that there
was a binding site for fencilidine
so first studies published in 1959
wasn't even known that there was a
binding site for fence cycloidine until
1979. now by binding site you mean a
receptor that it could a plate well some
kind of something some kind of something
they didn't know that it acted in a
specific way at a specific Target in the
brain what that Target was they didn't
yet know until the early 1980s that it
was a glutamate receptor yeah it's wild
they didn't even know that there was a
binding site for fence cycling until a
really
Landmark paper in 1979 from
Steve and Suzanne zukin so it was
Darkness right it was like the Middle
Ages
of Neuroscience
and so they they had a brilliant Insight
but they couldn't take it anywhere
because there was no framework for it so
joined the faculty in Ada at Yale and I
wasn't sure what I was going to do
and my boss said to me that Dr Chinese
said well you can be the
chief of the schizophrenia program or
the deputy chief of the PTSD program
and I I said well
I like the idea of being the chief
that's how I went into the field of
schizophrenia research and so I found
myself
as a new
completely
you know inexperienced
schizophrenia researcher setting up a
research program related to the
neurobiology and treatment of
schizophrenia
and it happened
to be just at that time that clozapine
which is an antipsychotic medication
that's a little bit more effective than
other antipsychotics I was introduced
and I've been raised studying monoamine
pharmacology that's what I knew that's
really
what I had anticipated studying and I
tried I treated patients with clozapine
and and I thought it was pretty good
medication
but I didn't want my legacy after 40
Years of schizophrenia research to be
that he figured out why clozapine was a
little bit more effective than other
antipsychotic medications so I felt like
I just had to
go out of the box
and you know this is um this is where my
father's Legacy really
had a big impact it's like
well if you could do anything
what would you do
and and it was like well I don't want to
study
these few cells
contributing to the
you know dopamine or norepinephrine I
want to study the main information
Highway of the brain just a few years
before they figured out that drugs like
ketamine PCP blocked this receptor for
glutamine
and so what brought me to ketamine
was really the effort to probe glutamate
synaptic function in higher cortical
circuits
as a way of understanding the cognitive
impairments negative symptoms and other
aspects of schizophrenia and so our path
in our Institution
my path
was
the development of a research program on
glutamate
psychopharmacology
developing circuit and mechanistic
hypotheses one of my collaborators in
those days was a pharmacologist named
beta mochada
and in 19
97
she published a paper
that showed that ketamine released
glutamate in the brain at the very same
doses that we were using the equivalent
of the very same doses that we were
using to produce changes in cognition
and psychosis related to schizophrenia
you know that line of research has its
own story because we began using the
ketamine Administration as a platform
for trying to identify novel
alternatives to antipsychotic medication
for the treatment of schizophrenia and
and that has had its own life and story
and maybe someday we'll we'll talk about
that but
one of the things beta found which
turned out to be profoundly important
for the antidepressant story
was if you give it at the sub anesthetic
dose that we use
to study cognition it released glutamate
if you give it at anesthetic doses it
depresses glutamine and it's not
antidepressant at those Doses and if you
give it at even a little bit lower level
it doesn't stimulate the glutamate
release so there's a tiny narrow window
where it's producing dissociation
psychosis and a number of the other
effects that we're really interested in
where it works
and turns out that that little narrow
dose window
is the dose range where it works for the
treatment of depression we just stumbled
on that
because it was optimal
you know the thing was we couldn't give
higher doses to people because we needed
them to
perform cognitive tests and be able to
answer our questions when we gave people
much higher doses of ketamine
they would have
you know pretty interesting experiences
but they couldn't answer any of our
questions so it wasn't any good for me
as a research tool I mean I remember one
person that we gave this higher dose of
ketamine to who
couldn't answer a lot of our questions
but he was holding on to the bed really
tightly
and I said well that's interesting why
were you holding onto the bed he said
well
basically the
the dress the blue and the dress of the
interviewer had become outer space the
white polka dots in her dress had become
planets and solar systems and his bed
was flying among the planets and the the
other planets and he was afraid that if
he let go of the bed that he'd be cast
adrift in outer space and and not make
it back well that was really fascinating
seems reasonable yeah it was really
really interesting but useless I
couldn't get him he couldn't do any
tests he couldn't perform anything so
what that essentially did was create
the upper bound of the dosing that we
were using with ketamine and then the
lower doses
just turned out to be completely
ineffective and have repeatedly been
shown to be so in in single doses in
antidepressant trials so that's how we
got to ketamine
and that's how we got to the dose of
ketamine and the route of ketamine that
we use in the treatment studies because
what we did was to adapt
the dose and the duration of
administration
like you could have said why 40 minutes
well because ketamine is such a
short-acting drug
we administer it for 40 minutes to give
us a Time window where people are having
the subjective effects of ketamine where
we can test behavioral and cognition
that's why we had the slow infusion in
the initial study
and we just imported that into
depression and that has become the
standard treatment
infusion Paradigm for racemic ketamine
Administration for the treatment of
depression